[Music]
[Applause]
he's a Hall of Famer he won two World
Series titles two MVPs and he's a
14-time All-Star Johnny Bench joining us
on the program
give me the names of the players in the
first All-Star Game you appeared in
well I was sitting in uh the Astrodome
uh staying in my locker because I didn't
want to trip anybody Spike anybody uh
and here goes uh you know here goes Bob
Gibson by or there's Willie Mason
straight across from me and of course
there's Ron Sato and Ernie Banks and
Billy Williams and then you know it was
such a lethargal walk by and and I'm
just taking it all in I'm 20 years old
uh Willie came across the room at Roman
came across the clubhouse look me just
straight now I said you should have been
to start and catching yeah
made my life made my life I got the
ninth inning of that game and it was a
thrill and uh gosh I mean to think about
the all-star teams and they think about
you know Washington was the next year
but the year we were in Detroit I think
there were 33 or fridge you'll know but
tell us Frenchie hi but uh 33 or 38 Hall
of Famers that actually were in the game
in Detroit
um that particular game that's one that
Reggie headed up into the light standard
and I hit one in right to center field
and Aaron hit one and McCovey and I mean
it was just you know it was so exciting
because we didn't play in our league
play we uh so here was Brooks Robinson
and Harmon Killebrew and all the guys
that were your Idols as a kid growing up
and here you are on the same field with
them did you call the pitch that Reggie
nearly hit out of Tiger Stadium
[Laughter]
the longest home run it would have gone
out if it didn't hit the light fixture
yeah but nobody talks about who called
that pitch
I didn't think we had to bring it up
really today even I thought unless
unless there's someone of your crack
staff thought about who called that
let's just talk about bench and his bad
fingers yeah okay
uh that that was one of those home runs
where you because Reggie never got
cheated like there there's certain guys
I don't know if there was anybody who
came to the plate
where they were sitting Dead red like he
didn't I don't know if he cared if he
struck out but he was going to get his
money's worth when he went to the plate
oh oh no he was there I mean he was he
was the original of what we see today
you know we see all the Grandeur and all
the excitement and all the and I'm still
working out on the fingers you know and
what they're doing and who they're doing
it to and what what it all is but uh
Reggie was that Reggie was so exciting
still is still is still still hungry
still anxious to do it uh you know to be
a part of it in the middle of it and
yeah he's still swinging at everything
that comes up there especially if it's
dead red we uh we had a caller called in
last hour and he said you know could you
bring this up to Johnny Bench that bill
freehand John walkenfuss uh you know
that they had CTE they had concussions
and we don't talk about that with
baseball but as a catcher have you you
know uh been looked at for that did did
you have your bell rung or have
concussions when you played
I probably had seven to ten concussions
during my time
um I got being three or four times I got
run over home played had a real bad car
accident when uh when I was 18 I'm sure
that uh I don't I'm surprised I even
walked out of that accident but yeah the
impact was a drunk driver driver on the
wrong side of the road uh and I passed
and started to pass the bus and there he
was he hit me right in the door so I can
imagine you can imagine the impact of
what that had on me and everything else
and and I've been doing a lot of studies
actually we're we're starting a
neurovisional Institute in Cincinnati
and my doctor uh friend has uh he treats
six to seven hundred concussion patients
a year because you can you can actually
uh get a concussion from a whiplash but
I've suffered through these things and I
started looking at this many years ago
uh because I was concerned about whether
it would cause Alzheimer's or dementia
yeah uh which did we wrote a paper with
the National Institute of Health with Dr
Ellison Dr Clark that talked about the
neurovisual side of the of the training
and uh yeah I'm I'm very aware of of
what what goes on and you know I'm
trying to be preventative that's why
I've joined with regeneron to uh on
their project to get everybody aware of
let's get real about skin care answer
I've had three different episodes I
actually had to have most surgery on
three of uh my eyelids my face my chest
and we're just asking everybody to go to
let's get real about skin cancer.com and
do excel self-examination now you go
into your dermatologist and you'll find
stuff and he may freeze them and use the
treatments and everything else to offset
them but uh yeah I I'm concerned about
what my future life would be that's why
I started in with this and so you know
you see the McMahon's and you see
different players and I've you know they
get their Bell rung I see guys get foul
balls you know and they just their eyes
cross and I never experienced that I saw
Stars you know I get to do in the Stars
you know I don't know if you've ever
heard that or saw that yeah yourself
well you were a basketball player you
were a contact player you know
a concert when you know when the Stars
start sprinkling I mean they actually
start to Sparkle yeah you can actually
see those things so yeah I'm doing
everything preventative if I can where's
my Funko
uh it's back behind fritzy I figured
that yeah it's right next to him we're
talking to Johnny Bench the uh Hall of
Famer did you hear the comments by Barry
Bonds that he said he's not he's
vindicating well Marvin would you play
he's on a podcast he was talking about
the Hall of Fame
people have to understand something is
that the fact of is that I was
Vindicated I went to the court I was in
federal court and I won my case 100
where is the Vindication of me and my
own sport that's what bothers me
what do you think is a Hall of Famer uh
should bonds be Mr bothering it should
bother him you know it's the same thing
with McGuire that you know they had it
and everything else we all assumed we
did we found Andrew or whatever it was
at the time which
definitely wasn't illegal supposedly in
those days I think uh Roger's been that
same situation uh you know there's
questions about certain Hall of Famers
that uh basically may have used uh you
know there's there's Shadows that have
been around it seems like there's a
selection process of who okay let's get
these three or four or five guys the
A-Rod uh Barry you know Roger Mark oh
let's get up let's get these guys and
we'll make uh you know
make them our guys
um and yet there's some you know where
there's questions about you have no
questions I mean you know you know who
there might be who was shadowed and
everything else and I I think that uh I
think as long as you know whether the
courts have done it you know or whether
we're going to be the fact that he's
guilty forever uh sounds like okay I've
been there I've done that he's speaking
out saying
you know what do I have to do the the
courts are but if they weren't testing
Johnny at the time what's that if they
weren't testing for steroids
that's what bonds is saying baseball
wasn't testing
well that was the thing that really came
out and during the time that um
uh when
cocaine was a part of it you know Marvin
Miller was really detested basically by
owners because Marvin Miller was a guy
who as being as part of the major league
baseball players Association he was sort
of delaying the fact of when the testing
could be because he I think he thought
that if the players were actually using
they needed to do something in order to
get them off of it let's give a year or
two and take that long they're blaming
Marvin for what became the steroid era
and I blame that I blame the trainers
because or physical trainers whoever
your guy was your the PT guy because
he's putting the stuff I call it the
blender era I think it's when you know
you're you're saying Hey I want to own a
belt muscle I say okay let's put this
powder and let's put this shark stuff in
there and we'll blend it and then the
guys next to you is bigger and stronger
and he said well what's he doing well
he's using this other powder and if you
went to GNC at the time or wherever
certain places were sold they didn't 90
percent of it had you know had the uh
the drugs that would actually build
muscle and do stuff and your performance
dancing and then you know they said well
what about now and then they said well
he takes a B12 shot or he takes whatever
shot and guys who made hit 12 home runs
you know next year at 8 40. all of a
sudden they're making from 3 million to
13 15 million and it's hard to say that
these guys you know at this point could
give a flip about what you know they
have the money in the bank they improve
themselves we all went you know
everybody to be bigger stronger better
and so they use that as a crutch and but
when you start putting your stuff in the
blender and start getting certain things
and developing help I'd have been the
you know I'd have loved to have stuff I
mean you catch 154 days in a row like I
did through one stretch you would have
loved to have had something that would
you know Revitalize you and try and get
you to the next level and so we've gone
through these different things in
baseball the Greenies the amphetamines
all the stuff that went along with it
you can drink uh you can take two
aspirin and drink a Coke you almost get
it you can take a diet pill and get the
get get it supposedly from what I'm told
so you know I played uh played without
him uh I remember one time though
and they were in the kit they were in
the trainer's kit I went in on a we
played like 15 Innings you're talking
about the amphetamines yeah and I came
in on Saturday and I Sunday I came in I
said I told the trainer I said I can't
move he opened up his kit and pulled out
a pill and said take this a half hour
later I didn't make it all I didn't I
you know and it's like well why wouldn't
you want to do this every day if you
could feel like this and then the next
year they banned it so now it's like you
taking Advil or Elite and they're
Tylenol or whatever and then tomorrow
they say no you can't take it any longer
and uh you would say wait a minute I
feel too good this is helping me I can I
can play golf I can I can run I can do
long all these things so you know the
Wonder bro is performance enhancing
but you're not wearing a Wonder Bra
right now are you
uh no no these are just real this is
some non-workouts I I actually am you
know trying to worry about not pulling a
fat muscle so everything else
um the shohei Otani phenomenon and it's
a dilemma with the angels what would you
do if you ran the angels with shohei
Otani at the trade deadline
Trading
no as a business person no as you know
you're probably going to lose him anyway
another year or whatever the contract
runs but it it's such a point where
Trout's hurt and everything else there
and they they ran through a period of
time they've spent eight jillion dollars
to try to do it
uh would I trade him yes as a business
person and an owner no I wouldn't trade
him because I would keep him as the
franchise he would be there and they
they're willing to spend money they're
willing to spend they just haven't done
it in the right way yet they've gotten
some players that haven't fit in or have
been hurt or whatever uh Trout's you
know Alabama much longer can he sustain
do they have you know somebody take the
Atlanta Braves you know and take their
blueprint and develop the minor Leaguers
and get this and every time they come up
with somebody get there all of a sudden
they're pitching which now we're hurt
again and all of a sudden you got
Strider and you got the Elder and you
got the guys that you know it's like
boom here they are and they're you know
and then they score six runs in the
first inning seemed like by the first
two or three Innings yeah they need to
take the blueprint I told you know the
Reds years ago I said you've got to
develop the pharmacist
uh Ellie De La Cruz remind you of
anybody oh you reminds me of you how
much excitement that you bring to this
whole deal I mean he is absolutely how
good is this I mean there's so many
great players oh my gosh there's so many
great players and and this kid the
excitement but it's it's like the
enthusiasm the you know the smile the
the what he does to a crowd what he does
to a Dugout and you know I'm watching
the game now and uh on Saturday or
Sunday and he was he was a shortstop you
know like Ron Hanson was back in the
White Sox days six foot six and then he
steals second third and then home and
and but but before that he's hitting in
the ninth inning he's driving and runs
into the Gap and he's a switch hitter
and it's like where in the heck did this
kid come from we've heard about it since
spring training well the most talented
player you ever saw was who
wow
uh
probably Willie Willie Mays yeah yeah I
mean you know obviously Joe Morgan is my
hero and one of the guys that could win
a game in every way and all that stuff
and and every day he could get a base
hit he could walk he could hit a home
run he get in a double he would steal 80
bases and everything else will he had
the flare Willie had the stuff and
everything else the athleticism he had
in the Outfield uh at the plate and just
uh the overall but you just were amazed
that you know him and Joe I guess more
than anything you know the name that
always comes to mind and he played in a
bad ballpark was Cesar cedenio
oh
he he was unbelievable and I'd go into
the training room they'd be stretching
him you know and they'd take his leg and
they put it back and you go back behind
his head he said he's so cheap I am so
steep I can't move it I couldn't get
them to at 90 degrees and he's like
Chief and he couldn't do it and he's
everything else that oh my gosh he's
funny bro he could hit and everything
else yeah he was talented uh let's get
real about skin cancer.com so uh you can
go to that website learn more and uh
take a pledge to see a dermatologist for
an annual skin exam will you do that
but are you seeing your dermatologist
yes I actually saw my dermatologist uh a
month ago and much to my wife's surprise
I came away with a great report
nice nice and that's the thing you can
have you know you can also self-examine
yourself you can also have somebody look
at you a spot or whatever in US I've had
the three different ones and everything
else and I have too many friends you
know Mike Schmidt has gone through so
many melanomas and everything else and
some of it uh squamous and some of them
have been the basal cell carcinoma but
uh these non-melanoma cancers you can go
in and you can take care of it you know
my my uh the boy's grandfather he looks
like he got hit by a paint gun every
time he goes to the dermatologist but
that's just the preventive medicine and
everything else yeah we I appreciate you
allowing us to talk about this because
I'm teaming with regeneron it's my
second year we've really got a lot of
the words out there a lot of the news
and notices out there for people too
please see your dermatologist and please
examine yourself
good to talk to you again Johnny thanks
for joining us so the boys I tell fritzy
to put my Funko up on next to Bobby
there it is and uh Johnny Bench Hall of
Famer fritzy it's right behind you I see
it I love it yeah he sent that in
or that was his uh son who I think uh
yes yes